joe dassin est ce que c'est la première
grande traversée qui fait un bateau non
on attendit que ça me connaît quand même
un peu j'ai fait une trentaine de fois
la traversée intérieur c'est comme femme
n'a jamais fait un nom de
bois-de-boulogne sa première fois la
majorité des voix puisque nous sommes
justement à la veille des vacances et
après en prélude aux vacances que nous
faisons aujourd'hui cette petite
promenade s'est tout même aussi la
période où on fait le point de l'année
puisque c'est en somme la fin de l'année
le travail pas pour vous qui vous partez
en vacances bien sûr en tournée alors le
point de l'année pour vous une très
bonne année ah oui ça je suis ravi de le
mée j'ai eu un bon deux très grandes
chances joie vers huy
d'abord sur le plan disent pas ce que
j'ai fait c'est quand même disque et
scène son plan déchets trois disques qui
ont marché chacun peut faire celui que
celui de vent et sur le plan scène
dans une très grande chance et que ces
partis en tournée avec salvatore adamo
qui d'abord sur le plan personnel êtes
un garçon adorable et aussi gentil que
professionnel l'ambiance d'autant les
formidables et deuxièmement
un énorme public qui lui aussi est très
gentil c'est assez exceptionnel
d'ailleurs je repars avec lui dans
quelques mois on va faire un petit bout
de ton nez gars vous avez des gros
succès du disque aussi cette année ce
comme je vous dis c'est chaque disque a
marché mieux que celui d'avant c'est ça
qui est formidable c'est vraiment sinon
si on pouvait choisir une façon de
marcher c'est comme ça qu'on choisirait
les dalton qui que je viens de sortir
marche qui me plaît beaucoup
le bbd mois maintenant que tout le monde
vous connaît on vous a fait un petit peu
plus connaissance avec vous vous êtes né
en amérique
je suis né en amérique mais je suis
devenu quand même entièrement français
de coeur et vous allez commencer à
chanter là bas oui mais j'étais déjà
venue en france c'est à dire que ma
famille est venue en france quand
j'avais
12 13 ans et je suis rentré là bas pour
faire des études universitaires parce
que j'ai envie de renouer un peu contact
avec mes origines je suis en partie en
cavale ans après mais j'étais
universitaire et je travaillais dans un
catholique en garçons et dans le café y
avait des gens qui venaient qui ça c'est
ça c'est sur une échelle et avait pas de
ses narines échelle pour que tout le
monde plus loin et j'ai chanté des
chansons folkloriques
ce serait quand même plus agréable de
chanter que de servir du café j'ai
demandé au patron si vous voulez bien
mais on pouvait chanter que du folklore
à cette époque là il va demander est ce
que vous connaissez les chansons
folkloriques et je lui ai dit oui parce
qu'il fallait bien fait seule chanson
que je connaissais tu fais des chansons
de brassens
je vais présenter comme du folklore
français les gens étaient ravis
d'ailleurs c'est pas loin de la vérité
un émissaire brassens c'est difficile de
faire déchanter gens sont 3 500 unités
brassens parce que c'est tellement
parfait tel que ses limites et c'est
peut-être pas tout à fait le mot en
rendant hommage
sa peau est bien rodée puisque
aujourd'hui c'était notre dernière
émission avant les vacances delà de
l'écran nous sommes heureux de vous
avoir eu comme dernier visible alors
maintenant vous allez commencer votre
campagne d'été ben voilà c'est ça c'est
le début des du grand travail pour nous
g j'essayais de mal et j'ai un peu la
tâche c'est qu'à cette époque on a
toujours la chanson où sont rencontrés
sur la plage
et puis nous ne verrons pas après
septembre et que je suis triste et que
tu es triste que nous sommes tous
tristes et vraiment c'est alors j'ai
fait un disque exprès en essayant de
faire ce que je pouvais plus gai tout
est un peu souple il ya le côté dalton
qui est complètement farfelu ensuite une
petite chansonnette pied qui rappelle
1920 c'est s'appelle alloué l'eau il ya
une chanson en fait de tout et tout est
fait pour pour sauter
je fais un truc ça donne bien envie de
voir le loup se tester c'est carrément
ça
tu me rends est plus douce et plus joli
qu'une demande allait entendre qu'une
fleur de safran
tu m'envoies avec des lettres
je mens je rêve d'un grand coup de dent